-Yet another former Trump
adviser is out
with a self-serving book about
their time in the White House.
Meanwhile, the committee
investigating the attempted coup
on January 6th interviewed
Trump's former attorney
for more than nine hours.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
There have been a flood of books
from former Trump advisers
since he left office.
And while most of them have been
dishonest and self-serving,
there's one coming out soon
that I think has the potential
to be refreshingly candid
and revealing.
And -- oh, wait, never mind.
It's Kellyanne Conway.
-Kellyanne Conway is the author
of a brand-new book,
"Here's the Deal,"
and she joins us now.
-Sorry, but the person
who famously coined the phrase
"alternative facts" does not
get to cash in on a book,
given that there's not a single
word of it we should believe.
I bet even the cover is a lie.
By Kellyanne Conway?
That probably means
her real name
is something like
Connie Anne Kellyway.
This book is also called
"Here's the Deal,"
which should be
an automatic red flag,
because usually when someone
says those words,
they've been caught in a lie.
"Gary, are you sexting
with your co-worker?"
"What? No. Why?"
"Because in your phone,
there's a notification
that says you have a new sext."
"Okay, here's the deal."
[ Laughter ]
"I thought it was the new iPhone
update, and I had no choice."
Also isn't "Here's the Deal"
a Joe Biden thing?
Is she trying to troll us all
by naming her book after a thing
Joe Biden famously says?
-Here's the deal.
Here's the deal.
-What's she gonna call
her next book?
"Look, Jack,
Get Your Facts Straight,
C'mon Man: My Time as
Barack Obama's Vice President"?
If you ask me, there's really
only one thing Kellyanne Conway
should be remembered for --
her snide response
to a question about COVID
being contained
in March of 2020.
-You talked about how
the administration
initially had this contained,
but during that time,
why didn't the administration
send out more tests
and work
to get hospitals prepared?
I mean, even today,
the state of Florida is saying
they can't test everyone per
the administration's guidelines
because they don't have
enough tests.
-So you're asking a couple
different things there.
I'll try to just
give some facts.
The HHS secretary said this
morning that we're ramping up.
We're ramping up
with the commercial labs --
-Why now? Why didn't they do it
while it was contained?
Get ahead of it?
-It is being contained.
And do you not think
it's being contained?
-Congrats, Kellyanne.
You were right.
It was contained in March 2020.
COVID quickly fizzled out.
Hydroxychloroquine
and horse paste worked,
and we never heard of it again.
Toilet paper was free
and plentiful.
No one was locked
in their homes for a year.
And I kept doing my show
in a suit and tie with a haircut
and a full, unmasked audience.
That's me from yesterday's show.
It was so good.
We did "A Closer Look"
about the first year
of Trump's second term
and how he has a 98% approval
rating after successfully
containing COVID,
winning the snowboarding
gold medal at the Olympics,
and wrapping with Dre
and Snoop Dogg
at the Super Bowl halftime show.
♪ My name is Trump,
and I'm here to say ♪
♪ I made COVID go away ♪
Wait, wait, wait.
No, I got that all wrong.
None of that happened, right?
COVID is still raging,
Trump lost the election,
and I spent a year in lockdown,
swatting away wasps and growing
out my hair like old Loki.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, wait.
Oh, God. Oh, God.
You know what that means?
This has been...
[ Thunder crashes ]
[ Eerie music plays ]
Wait. Is this the timeline where
Wally has luscious golden locks?
-You know it, baby!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Anyway, I'm not gonna
quote from the book
because there's no reason
to believe anything in it.
Conway was such a prolific
and shameless liar
that we shouldn't take a single
thing she says at face value.
In fact, that's how we should
treat anyone in the GOP
who backed Trump's big lie
about non-existent fraud
in the 2020 election.
Like for some reason,
news outlets keep inviting
on Republican politicians
to repeat the brazen
and unhinged lie
that the 2020 election
was somehow tainted.
Yesterday on CBS,
Florida Senator Rick Scott,
who objected
to the certification
of Pennsylvania's electoral
votes on January 6th,
even after the violent mob
stormed the Capitol,
implied that there was fraud
in the election
with very little pushback.
-There is clearly people
that are still concerned
about what happened in 2020,
and they would like
the facts to come out.
And they want
to know what happened...
-What do you mean by that?
-...why it happened.
Well, they want to know --
They want to know
that exactly what happened --
If, you know,
were there problems,
exactly what happened.
They'd like to know that.
But also, you know, they also
want to make sure we win in '22.
So, you know, they they want
to make sure that,
you know, we're going to make
sure their votes' not diluted.
So I think you have to -- you
have to talk about, you know,
making sure people understand
what happened in 2020,
but also make sure,
you know,
they know that you're going to
focus on making sure
that 2022 is a -- you know,
is a fair election.
-What do you mean, "They want
to know what happened"?
You know how many audits
and recounts we've had?
Does everyone need to get a turn
going through all the ballots
with a microscope
so they can personally confirm
that the 2020 election
was legit?
"Honey, what's all this?"
"Oh, they're ballots
from Georgia.
I guess it's my turn
to verify the results."
"But, honey, you don't know
anything about elections."
"That's what I tried
to tell them,
but they said it was my turn!"
[ Laughter ]
We know what happened.
Georgia reaffirmed
Biden's victory three times,
and even a Republican-sponsored
audit in Arizona,
conducted by a group
called the Cyber Ninjas,
confirmed Biden's win there.
And if you can't trust a group
called the Cyber Ninjas,
who can you trust?
[ Laughter ]
Cyber Ninjas sounds like
the name of an NFT
that originally sold
for $10,000
and now is going
for 5 bucks on eBay.
Meanwhile, cyber ninja
with an eyepatch
is now worth like $1,200,000.
And look, I'm not saying I own
the one without an eyepatch.
I'm just saying,
is the eyepatch one
really so much better?
[ Laughter ]
In fact, the Republican
search for voter fraud
was such a bust that Texas
Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick
offered a reward
for proof of voter fraud.
And one of the very few cases
that surfaced
was a Republican
in Pennsylvania
who used his dead mother's
ballot to vote for Trump.
So Pennsylvania's lieutenant
governor, John Fetterman,
who just won the Democratic
primary for Senate
in Pennsylvania last week,
said at the time that he would
accept Patrick's reward
in the form
of a gift certificate
to regional convenience store
Sheetz.
-The fraud that we know
that has occurred
in Pennsylvania in this cycle
is a registered Republican
in Luzerne County
trying to vote for Trump
with his dead mother's ballot.
Other than that, no,
we have not witnessed
any voter fraud
here in Pennsylvania.
I want my reward.
You know, he wanted voter fraud,
and from one fellow
lieutenant governor to another,
it's like, you know, he can
pay me in a Sheetz gift card.
That would be fine.
And the bottom line is,
like, you know,
my dude wants voter fraud?
I delivered it in Pennsylvania
because that is the one
lone case of voter fraud
documented right now,
as of this airing.
By the way, if you don't know
about Sheetz,
outside of New York,
it's the only place you can go
to buy mouthwash, fuzzy dice,
a 12-inch sub, and a six pack
of Keystone Light
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, if you want
to quietly slip
an adult magazine in there,
go for it.
It's not porn!
Sheetz don't sell porn.
It's something tasteful that
you can enjoy with your sub.
And by the way, I realize
I'm stepping into the middle
of an extremely fraught rivalry
here between Sheetz and Wawa.
I have an allegiance
to Pittsburgh,
but my staff is packed
with people from Jersey,
Philly, and,
worst of all, Delaware.
They all --
[ Laughter ]
They all insist
Wawa is better than Sheetz,
but I'm the host,
so I get to decide.
And to fans of Wawa,
I simply say...
[ Wah, wah! ]
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, back to Fetterman.
My favorite part of his demand
that Patrick pay him
the reward money
was a tweet he sent to Patrick
that ended with,
"P.S. The Cowboys blow."
[ Laughter ]
And even if you're
a Cowboys fan,
you have to admit
he's a man of his convictions,
because when he asked
about that tweet on CNN,
he did not back down.
-Well, let's first establish
the Cowboys do, in fact, blow.
[ Laughter ]
-At the end of the day,
this man is a unifier.
He may have driven a wedge
with this Sheetz endorsement,
but the whole state
can come together to agree
that the Cowboys [bleep] blow.
Also, I appreciate
Fetterman's willingness
to use football analogies,
like when he said that demanding
an audit of the election
was the equivalent of demanding
to be
added to the roster
of the Pittsburgh Steelers.
-I just want your viewers
to understand that --
that the people
that are involved
in these kinds of audits
in Pennsylvania
are not the sharpest knives
in the GOP drawer.
No one's taking this seriously.
I could issue a letter
on my office's letterhead
to the Pittsburgh Steelers,
saying, "I demand I be installed
as the starting left tackle
for the upcoming season,"
and that could generate
some new stories,
but it's not gonna go
anywhere, and neither is this.
-And this is coming from a guy
who, of all politicians,
has the best chance
of actually becoming
the starting left tackle
for the Steelers.
Dude is 6'9".
But he's certainly
right about one thing.
The people involved
in these scam audits
are not the sharpest knives
in the drawer,
which brings us, of course,
to a straight-up spoon,
Rudy Giuliani, who --
[ Laughter ]
who always
looks like he's surprised
to find out
he's Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, no, not that one, I hope!"
Rudy looks like
he just challenged Fetterman
to a bar fight,
and then realized
how tall Fetterman was
when he stood up.
"Oh, never mind! You can keep
talking to my wife, big guy.
Besides, she's my cousin.
It's unnatural."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Rudy was, of course,
integral to the failed attempt
to overturn the results
in various swing states,
including specifically
in Pennsylvania.
And as a result, the committee
investigating the coup conducted
a virtual interview with him
last week that lasted for hours.
-Some big news
from the January 6th committee.
Tonight, in the past hour,
we have learned
that President Trump's
personal lawyer,
former New York Mayor
Rudy Giuliani,
testified today
before the 1/6 committee.
NBC News confirms that Giuliani
testified virtually
for approximately 9 hours.
-9 hours?
I mean, I guess it makes sense.
The dude was involved in almost
every aspect of the coup,
so there's a lot to discuss.
Either that or he kept
having technical difficulties.
"Excuse me, Mr. Giuliani,
you have your thumb
over the camera."
"No, that's just my face.
It looks like a thumb
with eyes drawn on it."
[ Laughter ]
Let's not forget Rudy
once butt-dialed a reporter,
left a voicemail
for the wrong senator,
and has repeatedly shown
off evidence implicating himself
in Trump's crimes on his various
devices during TV interviews.
-It's all here.
Right here.
The first call
from the State Department.
Here's Kurt saying,
"Great.
I will tell Yermak,
and he'll visit with you there.
Thanks."
"Mr. Mayor, how was your meeting
with Andriy?
Do you have time for a call?
Best Kurt."
They're all over me,
you know, asking me to do it.
I was happy to do it.
-The feds didn't need
to knock down his door.
They just had to watch Fox News.
"Hey, can we get one
of our forensic guys to zoom in?
Yeah, no, there it is."
[ Laughter ]
Honestly, I'm just shocked Rudy
was able to make it
to an Apple Store
without confusing it
for a fruit stand.
"Oh, I'll take that yellow phone
right there.
Boss, I got big news."
[ Laughter ]
"We won on appeal.
Also, boss,
I got something to tell you.
They definitely put my head
on someone else's body."
[ Laughter ]
"Boss, can we go
to the full-frame again?
I think that this is
definitely a case where my head
has been put on
a different person's body."
[ Laughter ]
"Sometimes it's seamless,
and you can't tell,
but this is clearly
not my body, boss."
[ Laughter ]
"We had to find
a picture of a body
that was holding the phone
that looked like a banana."
[ Laughter ]
The point is,
Republicans are very much
still engaged to this day
and preparing for the next coup,
which is why they're still
so invested in lying about
or covering up the last one.
The GOP nominee for governor
in Pennsylvania
is a full-on pro-insurrectionist
who wanted to overturn
the state's electors in 2020.
We can't allow Republicans
who supported the big lie
back
into the political mainstream
because whatever they pretend
to be in the streets,
Republicans are still opposed
to democracy in the...
Sheetz.
[ Laughter ]
-Um, guys, that was not
the easiest "Closer Look"
for me to get through.
Not only is what we're
talking about very serious,
but Wally's had the wig
on the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh...
you know,
if you think back,
the wig was really early.
[ Laughter ]
The wig was really early,
in "Closer Look," and, uh...
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
And so, like,
while I'm talking about --
You know, again,
I'm talking about things
that are really gonna affect us,
also, in the back of my head
that whole time, I'm like, "Why
didn't you take the wig off?
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna ask him
during the commercial break.
I'll let you know
if it was a good answer.
We'll be right back
with Billy Crystal.
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.